steve bannon was the man who whispered
in president donald trump's ear and they
both believed that gave bannon the right
to ignore a call to testify before the
january 6th committee
on friday a federal jury needed fewer
than three hours to decide that by doing
so bannon broke the law in the closing
argument
the prosecutor
missed one very important phrase
right i stand with trump and the
constitution and i will never back off
that ever
the january 6th committee had wanted to
know just how much bannon knew about
trump's plans to disrupt the
certification of the 2020 presidential
election and stay in office as a result
it wasn't asking for information about
the attack on the capitol itself
even so bannon not only refused to
testify he also refused to share any
documents or communications with the
panel
the committee in turn called on the
justice department to prosecute bannon
he's already planning his appeal on
grounds the prosecution misled the jury
they argued to the jury today that when
a person gets a subpoena an executive
privilege is invoked it's for congress
to decide whether the executive
privilege is valid and how broad it is
that's absolutely false steve bannon is
expected to be sentenced in october he
could face up to a year in prison and a
thousand dollar fine for each of the two
guilty convictions
rosalind jordan al jazeera